my name is blair metcalf i work here
uh i've worked here for four years i
actually work in another building
and i'm a ux engineer i'm here to tell
you about what ux engineering means
um i'm gonna go through a couple stories
and then like
end on a demo and hopefully if
everything goes right the demo will
crash
uh which is normal so you may be sitting
there
asking yourself a few questions who am i
um i'll go over that i'll give you a
little bio
and and there's a reason to the bio
it'll give you timeline
of like flip-flopping between design and
development
i'll tell you why i'm talking at you why
it's important
ux engineers demos are often the most
um can you help me out with this monitor
over here
demos are often the most powerful
things in any meeting and so the
prototyper is actually the most
powerful person in the meeting i'll go
over
like how you do this um and then i'll
prove it
and then i will give you something to
walk away with i don't think we're gonna
get that screen
no no look over here
[Laughter]
um okay so i'm gonna go through my
portfolio really
quickly because it starts to show um
a split between design and development
to a recruiter
i look like a weirdo i look like a bad
designer and a bad developer but when
you
when you smush them i'm i'm i'm a
unicorn
so i've done everything i've owned
businesses i've designed i've developed
and over the course of 15 years i think
i've done everything
and so if you look at this timeline
starting around the turn of the century
i started making mcdonald's dot com
cadillac.com
for big agencies and then i use that put
it in my portfolio and i worked off-site
for years six years never met my boss i
worked in flash
people may hate on this but it's one of
the best things that's ever been made
for front end
yes it is um i work for microsoft i work
for t-mobile i work for zoon
you can hate on that too
and i did all this off-site i had
several code libraries
that that allowed me to go really fast
um
towards the end of that i pitched to a
friend
hey we're really good at what we do
let's stop working for other people and
we started our own business
i did front end i did the design he did
the back end
and so i'm just going to quickly show
that so that
of the work that i've done i've worked
on all of these logos
and there's a product that we made
called pillow mob and i think that this
is sort of important
into to what i do um pillow mob
is a company that turns your head into a
pillow
you send us a photo we send you your
head as a pillow and you put it on your
couch
in two weeks and so what we did is we
prototyped it
we went out and we bought an expensive
printer we tried to print on fabric
and then slowly but surely we figured
out how to print on
fabric um i designed it
he built the back end we made sure that
we had a fulfillment
uh ordering system and then within three
months and spending 200 bucks
we ended up on the nbc today show we got
you know 100 000 views in one day um and
so this is this is what it looks like
so that's my wife and she's sleeping
with another man
um there is a commercial you can look
this stuff up it's called pillow mob
your couch or mine um this is kathie lee
and hoda
drinking wine at 10 a.m with pillows
of my dog and my my baby
um and the the whole idea which
which was sort of funny back then um
was push and pull the idea was cute and
creepy
and and lo and behold years later that's
all that politics is
it's like this kind of 50 50 of push and
pull
and that was our marketing campaign it
was a bottom-up thing okay
so moving on there's this split between
design and development and that's what
that's what a uxe is
and and i think often when i go to
meetings
i want to i want to walk in with work i
want to have a demo
it anchors everything that i say to that
demo
the person with the demo is the most
powerful person because often
everybody uses words they say words they
have words in decks
and everybody nods their heads and they
agree but nobody knows what they're
agreeing to
a prototype is different everybody knows
what they're agreeing to
so this is a cgi
picture of like the law the mars rover
landing and when i see this what i see
is a prototype come to life and so i
imagine when they started to build this
they were like how can we land an egg
by throwing it off of the fremont bridge
without breaking the egg
and i start to see that you know these
these kinds of things come to life
and when prototypers make their
prototypes realistically they're going
through these questions and they're like
how can we land
this product so i want to go into a
tool that i started working on here
hopefully it'll be public
in a few months
who here works with designers
as a developer and then who is a
designer and they work with
developers and then i guess all the
other
hands are other people like are you in
the software
industry can i get a hand for that okay
in general there's there's this there's
this split between design and
development
there's a there's a kind of handoff and
there's always this tension between
designers and developers
designers don't know what they're
talking about developers are too
rigid and stiff um
and there's a problem designers speak in
certain mediums
developers speak in other mediums here
we have the material spec
and you can see like an app bar you can
see some buttons and
different things and they spec those out
they make bitmaps they make pixels
and then they go and they make a sticker
sheet in sketch and this is a way that
you can drag and drop these
pixels and you can make comps mocks
quicker
but then the engineers go on to make
demos of the components and to a degree
each of these roles own the thing that
they made and there's really no
easy conversation between the two and
it's all duplicate effort
sometimes they throw things over the
wall and they hope for the best
and so what we started to think was can
we make a tool where designers and
developers are working in the same tool
and there's this conversation
so just imagine what if you had a
development environment that you can
design in
and you get google docs comments
you could start to have conversations
about the flows that you're laying out
you could say there's a bug in this
in this component this one you know
needs a variant etc
so we started to prototype this um
this is an internal tool it's called
cloud kit
it is it there is a blog post about it
so i'm not revealing anything
but what you see here is the project
view
across the top you can name it it shows
the saved at
time there's a viewport you can change
the dimensions of the page that you're
on
in the top left you can add a component
and below that
is the dom tree and you can start to
select
different elements and then add elements
to that scope
and the idea here is it's a
drag-and-drop wysiwyg
for live components that you can
lay out flows prototypes and prototype
quickly
this should be another slide and it
should show
bringing in data and so here we have a
table component
and then we hook that up to a google
spreadsheet it has an id
and then you don't configure all of the
rows columns and cells
you configure the spreadsheet and then
that sucks in all the data and populates
the table it's a very fast way
to to make flows and so what we did
was we used this prototype and we
started
to show it around it got a lot of
excitement
it went all the way up the chain and
we got funding and so i just want to
give a quick little demo of that here
and if everything goes wrong there's
going to be a ton of errors and nothing
will work
but what you get across the side is a
series of panels where you can
visually find a component you could
search for it there's different
filters for that component and you can
drag and drop that
in place and see where it reflows
there's no
there's no need to write code you can
drag and drop everything
there's a styles panel where you could
as we're building this right now
you can bind typography throughout the
app
systemically there's a place for data
where you could
as i showed that spreadsheet you could
populate a component with a lot of data
and then you can drag and drop images
and so also at the bottom
you can start to write code and you can
see where
your drag and drop code ends up and i
took these from the angular material
site and just pasted these in this page
here
is a custom
library we call it fortnightly this is
just from material design
and you can make your own components
import them
and work with your designers with their
code up here is a preview button and
then you can preview
the prototype that you've made it clicks
through to all the pages
and then you can comment on specific
elements
you can go through the different pages
and then you can see a full view and
then poof there's your prototype
and you can come back and
start designing again so the idea here
is you make a small prototype
you show the vision and then you go
bigger
all right
so in the end if you don't have any
questions
there are not there's nothing to
prototype you would never prototype
a table everybody knows how a table
works unless you're going to add some
kind of new filter
what if you had tabs under a filter
above a table
well let's see how that could work maybe
everybody hates it we prototype it
prototypes answer questions if you have
no conflict on your team you may not
need a prototype
and then clicking is believing everybody
makes mocks i'm convinced the more
complicated the mocks get
actually people are lost between the
clicks it's just a
quick change between the mock and nobody
knows
what did that when you click right if
you click on it yourself
you know the whole flow
and with that come find me i'm pretty
friendly i won't bite your head off
uh if you have any questions about ux
engineering at google
we are hiring um it is a public post
search for fremont seattle kirkland ux
engineer
and i just like meeting people so tell
me what your goals are i want to hear
them
thank you
do you do q a or uh yeah actually let's
do a q a
section now yeah okay cool great are
there any questions
yeah hit me um because it was
on the far side there but when you're
building out the controls there
um what is it that the developer gets
was that at the very bottom the
html the dom yeah that what's what's
fascinating
um is that we are actually generating
real code it's there's no proprietary
other language and so we're storing html
the angular template
we're storing css and so in the end you
can actually download
the zip and with an mpmi npm start
it runs within two minutes but we also
export to stack blitz and we open
in 10 seconds um and so nicole
one goal that we have is to replace
stack blitz
in ng girls with co-design
yeah let's do it
anything else yeah at what point you
described a little bit of a process here
for
how you're approaching these problems at
what point you start to incorporate
design systems
oh yeah design systems are huge it's the
it's the economics of you know design
and engineering
there's a lot of speed to it um i work
on google cloud
and that is essentially like my whole
life
um so it's design systems are non-stop
we have like a memorization of the
components we have a memorization of the
styles
people notice when things are off so i
would say all the time
however as you get bigger that design
system
is actually a friction and and so that's
where this
this kind of tool comes in um
and and i i would actually say that like
google cloud is suffering
from that and we're trying to figure out
how to go faster
but a design system has pros
and cons
sorry continue just a quick expansion
yeah
in um flow i guess you're spending a lot
of it seems like you're spending a front
time
to expand and define some of the systems
modifying
because you're bringing in an existing
design system with
material and the
oh yeah that's right yeah you saw the
clarity right right right
so how how do you envision uh developers
or designers
interacting with that don't exactly have
an information or
yeah so with this tool we see that
there's a great partnership between
angular
the framework and then other angular
libraries material and then it's google
cloud hosted
and so with material you get themes they
have several themes
and what you can do with this tool is
you can modify some of those
settings and you could export that
into your your your export your download
your zip
um so you wouldn't have to know it the
point of it would be that it's a ui
that would walk you through that yeah
hopefully we we make it invisible
yeah thank you yeah you someone had a
question
like do you want to write plugins or do
you want do you want your own templates
so that yeah that that's another aspect
to it i didn't show the dashboard but
um one of the ideas is you would have
teams
and those teams would have would have
patterns under there
and so you would be able to make a
project
and it would be a pattern and then you
can publish that so this is actually a
ui
building platform you could make a
component and you can share that and the
idea is
is that it's all reuse for designers to
go faster
over here
we are hiring at this office
oh was i yes i was hired here um yeah
and then
uh just a quick background i think the
short of it is
i don't belong here and i
thoroughly believe that and i've
taught myself over the course of years i
taught myself angular in fall
and i started in ios and they said do
front end that was really difficult
and i think it takes a mixture of skills
to work with
hundreds of people it doesn't
necessarily mean that you have to know
the
the technology the best it's how do you
get
ish done yeah
yes um you mentioned before that uh
you can plug in other libraries besides
materials
would that include like prime ng or
extract bootstrap yeah yeah all these
um so what what's needed is that we have
a cli
that runs through your your library your
umd bundle
and then what we are working on is a
standardization of your inputs and
outputs and so then we could sit there
instead of just saying it's a string
it's a boolean we can actually say it's
a color
it's more complex hopefully we'll work
with interfaces
and so that you could pass in complex
structured objects
but we will have a cli to
import your library
put on is signature or is there like a
substitute
yet design tends to be
mocks depending on who you work with it
could be
systems and ux engineers
scale design significantly different
it's not
just um like a bespoke ui it's like how
can we make this reusable
great how can 10 000 people use this
significantly different thought process
yeah all right oh
one more time
i'm gonna get hate mail for this i'm
sorry
none of it matters i'm not kidding um
like i've developed ui
in a bajillion languages and in the end
like
there are rough differences one of my
favorite books is just
a javascript design pattern book and
in the end like you take different
patterns from different frameworks
but none of it matters if if you are
learning the language you'll sit there
and you'll figure out
what it is that you want to do um you
know
angular tends to be more enterprisey and
react
tends to be trendier hipper
more consumer what do you want to do and
then go learn
that framework
well i mean just straightforward i mean
react is is is great
google is is fragmented and the products
will pick out
what is best for them and so
you may find a google product that uses
react
but there's no mandate
yeah yeah all right
i've taken enough time thank you very
[Applause]
much